The stars of "Jurassic Park" have been in
some certified classics – and they've also
been in some of the worst movies ever made.
From straight-to-video sequels to films that
zero critics liked, these are the horrible movies
"Jurassic Park" actors hope you forget about.
You'd be hard-pressed to find a more reputable
actress in Hollywood today than Laura Dern.
She has starred in more than 60 feature films,
and was even nominated for two Academy Awards
before finally taking home her first Oscar in 2020
for her poignant performance in "Marriage Story."
Dern has been appearing in movies since 1973,
and throughout her decades-spanning career she's
shone in some truly unforgettable roles,
arguably none more popular than that of
paleobotanist Ellie Sattler in "Jurassic Park."
If Dr. Sattler is Dern's most memorable role,
however, perhaps her most forgettable
part came years later in 2010's undeniably
lackluster "Little Fockers," the third and final
installment in the "Meet the Parents" trilogy.
Despite reuniting Ben Stiller, Robert De Niro,
and Dustin Hoffman, the trilogy-capper ended
the once-promising comedy series on a very
low note. Most people probably don't even
remember that this movie exists, let alone
that Laura Dern plays a very small part in
it as an elementary school headmistress named
Prudence. Ironically enough, Dern must not have
been exercising much prudence when she decided
to sign on for this terribly unfunny comedy.
Before he got ripped to play Star-Lord in
2014's "Guardians of the Galaxy," Chris Pratt
wasn't exactly the guy that movie studios had
on speed dial when they needed an action hero.
"Starlord."
"Who?"
"Starlord, man. The legendary outlaw?"
Fast-forward a few years, however,
and things have certainly changed.
In addition to his wildly popular portrayal
of the Galaxy's favorite snarky hero in the
"Guardians of the Galaxy" movies,
Pratt has also headlined another
multimillion-dollar franchise as velociraptor
trainer Owen Grady in 2015's "Jurassic World."
As Grady, Pratt got to showcase his
effortless acting chops with both bold,
unapologetic machismo and
grounded everyman humility.
He's also been a part of a movie that failed on
almost every level. "Movie 43," which was marketed
as a star-studded racy comedy, is undoubtedly
the worst film on Pratt's resume. With a lowly
4% score on Rotten Tomatoes, this jumbled mess
of a movie took home three Razzies in 2014,
including the Worst Picture award. While Pratt
shouldn't shoulder much of the blame for the
awful final product, you have to assume that he
hopes "Movie 43" never comes up in interviews.
Jeff Goldblum is the kind of performer who
can take virtually any role and make it a
fan favorite. His filmography consists of
over 135 acting credits and is chock full
of unforgettable movies and characters, including
Seth Brundle in 1986's "The Fly," David Levinson
in 1996's "Independence Day," and of course,
Dr. Ian Malcolm in 1993's "Jurassic Park."
Goldblum's unique acting prowess is beyond
question, but with such an expansive filmography,
there are bound to be a few misses to coincide
with all the hits. Perhaps his most notable
failure was that of 2015's "Mortdecai," in
which Goldblum plays a shady art dealer,
Milton Krampf. Arguably the worst Johnny Depp
movie of all time, "Mortdecai" plays like a
cheap "Austin Powers" knockoff. Even the talented
core cast consisting of Depp, Gwyneth Paltrow,
and Ewan McGregor couldn't save this action
comedy from colossally flopping at the box office.
Vincent D'Onofrio has a knack
for playing really good bad guys.
You might not have even recognized him
as Edgar, the creepy unwitting host of a
nefarious cockroach alien in 1997's "Men in
Black," or as the bald crime boss, Kingpin,
in Marvel's "Daredevil" and "Hawkeye." He
also played the main antagonist Hoskins,
the head of InGen's security force, in "Jurassic
World." A self-proclaimed method actor,
D'Onofrio has turned in some incredibly
believable performances over the years.
However, there have been a few less
than believable performances, too.
In 2017's "Rings," a sequel to 2002's "The
Ring," D'Onofrio played a blind caretaker
with a secret connection to the ghostly Samara.
As Peter Sobczynski of RogerEbert.com put it,
he seems to be playing the role for an
easy paycheck and absolutely nothing else.
Not exactly the kind of criticism you'd
expect to hear about an actor who once
gained a whopping 70 pounds just to play
Private Pyle in "Full Metal Jacket."
"This is my rifle! There are many
like it, but this one is mine!"
Still, D'Onofrio was hardly the main
issue in "Rings," an incoherent film
that's branded with an 8%
rating on Rotten Tomatoes.
Sam Neill is no stranger to being in front of
the camera. With nearly 150 acting credits,
the New Zealand native has been performing in
movies and TV shows since the early '70s. His
most recognizable role is obviously that of Dr.
Alan Grant from the "Jurassic Park" franchise, but
he's also starred in plenty of excellent films.
"Irresistible," however, is not one of them.
Despite a talented leading trio of Neill, Susan
Sarandon, and a young, pre-fame Emily Blunt,
this 2006 dramatic thriller went straight to DVD.
The premise was simple enough: Sarandon becomes
suspicious that she's being stalked by Neill's new
secretary, played by Blunt, and paranoia ensues.
It's honestly quite similar to other popular
movies like "The Hand That Rocks the Cradle"
and "Sleeping with the Enemy," but lacks any of
those films' ability to tell a compelling story.
"Irresistible" currently boasts a 20% critical
score on Rotten Tomatoes, which could certainly be
worse. However, what's arguably the grossest facet
of the movie is the uncomfortable age gap between
Sam Neill and Emily Blunt. Neill was born in 1947,
and Blunt was born in 1983, making him roughly 36
years older than his co-star. It's quite an
age gap, even for a Hollywood blockbuster.
During a 2020 appearance on The Graham
Norton Show, legendary actor Samuel L.
Jackson proudly declared that he
loves watching his own movies.
Apparently, not only does he buy $1,000 worth
of tickets for his new films when they first hit
theaters, but he also frequently rewatches his
older flicks when he's bored at home. He said,
"If I'm channel surfing and
there's nothing else on,
I'll go into the search engine and go 'Samuel
L. Jackson...' I pick one and I watch it."
While Jackson has been in too
many iconic movies to even name,
there's one film, in particular, that's hard
to imagine he would ever want to rewatch.
"Hold onto your butts."
In 2004, Oscar-nominated screenwriter Philip
Kaufman directed a movie called "Twisted,"
a mystery thriller that stars Ashley Judd as a
police detective trying to catch a serial killer.
Jackson played the police commissioner who,
unsurprisingly is revealed to be the killer.
Despite the combined star power of Judd,
Jackson, and Andy Garcia, critics found
incredibly little to like about "Twisted,"
blasting it down to a 1% on Rotten Tomatoes.
Ariana Richards was only 12 years old when
she played Lex Murphy, the adolescent computer
nerd hacker in "Jurassic Park," but she was
apparently so good at displaying genuine terror,
that even director Steven Spielberg
was impressed. As she told Den of Geek,
"When we were filming the scene of the T-rex with
the jeep, … Steven came over to me once and said,
'Ariana, you reach such a deep level of
fear and terror –- what do you draw from?
Were you scared by a clown when you were
three? Don't tell me, I don't want to know!'"
Perhaps one of the events that Richards drew
fear from was reading critics' reviews of
"Spaced Invaders," a movie she starred
in three years before "Jurassic Park."
The hammy sci-fi comedy followed a
group of short, bumbling aliens who,
after overhearing a radio broadcast
of "War of the Worlds," invade Earth
on Halloween night, only to be mistaken for
trick-or-treaters in a small American town.
Although audiences didn't seem to hate
"Spaced Invaders," critics tore it to
pieces in their reviews. Roger
Ebert bashed the film, writing,
"One of the purposes of growing
up and getting an education is
to learn why movies like 'Spaced
Invaders' are a waste of time."
Of all the actors in "Jurassic Park,"
only BD Wong returned to reprise his role,
that of InGen's chief geneticist
Dr. Henry Wu, in "Jurassic World."
Although he was reportedly hesitant
to slip back into Dr. Wu's shoes,
Wong once again found himself right smack
dab in the middle of a dino disaster.
The "Jurassic Park" franchise is undoubtedly
Wong's most popular work, but he's also excelled
in other areas throughout the years, including
successful TV series like "Gotham," "Mr. Robot,"
and "Law & Order: Special Victims Unit." He
also voiced Shang in Disney's animated classic,
"Mulan." However, it hasn't all been sunshine
and critical roses for the former Broadway star.
In 1998, Wong had the misfortune
of starring in "The Substitute 2:
School's Out," a straight-to-cable sequel
with almost no connection to its 1996 crime
thriller predecessor. Wong played
one of the bad guys, but honestly,
the lazy outing is so poorly put together that
the good guys are pretty bad, too. The movie has
a rare 0% Rotten Tomatoes score — not exactly the
kind of grade you want on your acting report card.
When "The 5th Wave" hit theaters in January of
2016, it's easy to imagine that Sony and Columbia
Pictures were banking on a possible franchise.
After all, the movie was based on the first novel
in Rick Yancey's literary trilogy, so there's
definitely plenty of source material to work with.
However, after an onslaught of dismal reviews
and a very disappointing box office pull,
any future sequels seem to
be unlikely at this point.
"Are we still alive?"
"I think so."
In the explosive sci-fi flick, Nick Robinson, who
co-starred as an angsty teen amidst a dinosaur
breakout in "Jurassic World," plays an angsty
teen amidst an alien invasion. Co-starring with
Chloë Grace Moretz, Ron Livingston, and Liev
Schreiber, the "5th Wave" cast tried their best
to keep the ambitious action movie from imploding
into a million pieces, but they were ultimately
unsuccessful. While it's hardly the first young
adult novel movie adaptation to flop, you have to
assume that Robinson wishes he would've just said
"pass" when the casting director came calling.
Have you ever watched a movie that's so
over-the-top emotional that it seems as
if the whole film was created with the
sole purpose of making the audience cry?
That's exactly what it feels like to watch 1995's
"Three Wishes," a sappy family drama starring
Patrick Swayze, Mary Elizabeth Mastrantonio,
and "Jurassic Park" child star Joseph Mazzello.
The story follows a mother
who lets a drifter named Jack
stay with her and her two sons after
accidentally hitting him with her car.
As you can probably predict, there's more to
Jack than meets the eye, and he begins to form
a special bond with the young boys, becoming
the father figure that they were missing.
It's easy to criticize corny movies like this,
but people do find enjoyment in clichéd feel-good
stories. This probably helps explain the
52% audience score that "Three Wishes"
holds on Rotten Tomatoes. Critics, however,
had different opinions. Roger Ebert wrote,
"The movie lays it on so thick that
even with the best will in the world,
I couldn't go along on its slow and soppy ride."
For whatever reason, film adaptations of Dan
Brown's crowd-pleasing Robert Langdon novels,
like "The Da Vinci Code" and "Angels and
Demons," are never well received by critics.
Even with Ron Howard in the director's
chair and Tom Hanks playing the lead,
the mystery thrillers just don't
translate to the big screen.
Hanks' third attempt at Langdon, 2016's
"Inferno," was another example of this.
"Inferno" starred Hanks and "Rogue One" breakout
Felicity Jones as the two main characters,
but it also had a solid supporting cast, including
two guys who had just starred in "Jurassic World"
the year before, Omar Sy and the late Irrfan
Khan. Although both actors are extremely talented,
Sy was nominated for a Golden Globe
for his work on Netflix's "Lupin," and
Khan accrued a slew of accolades for his
work in both Hollywood and India, not even
their acting abilities could save "Inferno"
from going up in flames at the box office.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.